- The diversity and the
range of Flemish patterns,
and colors, and forms of the chickens
are just fascinating.
You've really got to like it.
It's kind of dusty, dirty, noisy.
(chickens crowing)
Very noisy.
But, it's sort of fun and
gratifying in its way.
(chickens squawking)
(fast-paced cello music)
I'm Tom Whiting, owner
and founder of Whiting Farms
in Delta, Colorado.
We're a poultry genetics
and production company
that specializes in fly tying feathers.
For reasons I can't even remember why
I started raising poultry when
I was about 10 years of age
and I just never cease to find
it an interesting subject.
(plastic scraping)
I'm sure most people think
they know what feathers are.
But really feathers are highly specialized
elongated reptilian scale.
It's just evolved into feathers.
A major function is sexual selection
meaning that the roosters
have very brilliant
and very showy feathers.
So, the rooster with the finest feathers
might get the most hens.
And those feather traits
get increased over time.
It takes almost a year
to grow the roosters
from baby chicks.
I think we've settled in the
80,000 range at any one time.
Chickens, because they're small
and they reproduce very quickly,
we can radically alter how
the birds grow their feathers.
(chickens squawking)
It's amazing how much with
selection the birds can have
their feathers change over
times and generations.
This one's going to Colorado,
Salt Lake City,
Massachusetts,
Sweden, Germany, Norway,
Wales, Denmark, Kenya.
This whole order right
here I know is going
waiting to go to Japan.
Rooster feathers are used
in tying fishing flies
or they have been for
hundreds of years we know.
Because they're a defensive feather
so they have some rigidity to them
that rests on the surface
tension of the water
and it looks like an insect to the fish.
And the fish will see it and the dimples
it makes in the water,
and they'll want to strike that.
And that's the way the
fisherman catches the fish.
(line whooshing)
One of the reasons I'm in
this business is I like
just dealing with the birds.
I find them endlessly fascinating.
And my favorite time of day
is often when I'm going out
through the birds on a daily basis
and looking at them,
seeing how they're doing.
And I feel like I know them intimately
and I handle every bird in the system.
I've seen the trajectory or the arc
of where the feathers have come from.
But I don't view this as
something that I'm doing,
it's rather I'm doing it for a while.
And I feel a responsibility
to cultivate them
in a responsible way,
protect them from diseases
so they don't get wiped out,
and so they'll be available
for as long as people
want to tie fishing flies.